[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 11 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction on
commence tout de suite avec les titre de
cette édition Bernard casneu ministre de
l'Intérieur de l'Intérieur pardon
présente ses V aujourd'ui à satori
quartier général du GIGN une manière de
saluer les différentes unités et de
passer en revue les moyens utilisés lors
des récents
attentats samedi enfin a eu lieu le
Conseil d'installation de SaintQuentin
en Yveline Michel logier est reconduit
président de l'agglomération alors que
l'opposition quitte l'exécutif le point
à suivre dans notre édition une avocate
devenue humoriste dans notre chronique
culture rencontre avec Caroline Vigot
nouvelle star montante du standup
bientôt à l'Olympia et enfin nous
recevons dans ce journal Jacques
Fournier directeur d'itinéraire poétique
de saint-cortin en iveline et ala
Mohamad poète et sciénaste syrienne
bonsoir à vous deux vous allez nous
parler de la soirée pour lutter contre
l'obscurantisme au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en iine qui a lieu ce soir
le 11 janvier suite aux attentats de
Charlie Hebdo et du supermarché hyper
cacher nous y reviendrons dans quelques
instants et saquentin en yeline a élu
samedi son président Michel logier a été
réélu avec 48 suffrages sur 50 possibles
dans la foulée les 11 vice-présidentes
ont été accord vice-présidents sont été
accordés aux élus de sa majorité avec
CIN nouvelles communes en 30
l'agglomération se trouve devant de
nouveaux challenge retour sur ce conseil
d'agglomération avec Patrick Jacques de
dixmud et Fanny
Bourdillon depuis 10h Michel logier a
été réélu ce samedi président de la
nouvelle agglomération de 50 ans en
Yveline rebaptisé simplement 50 ans en
Yveline elle passe de 7 à 12 communes
avec l'arrivée de plaisir les clés
sous-bois Villepreux coignère et morpa
l'intercommunalité compte désormais
230000 habitants c'est une nouvelle
aventure parce que c'est déjà un nouveau
territoire c'est un nouveau territoire
avec d'autres enjeux regardez tout
simplement aujourd'hui nous avions trois
gares sur le territoire nous en aons SEP
nous avons SEP désormais c'est un grand
retour pour les villes de plaisir morpa
et coignère qui avaient quitté en 1984
l'intercommunalité qu'on appelait à
l'époque la ville nouvelle après 30 ans
d'absence morpa donc intègre
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Eveline la nouvelle agglomération et
donc déjà c'est une fierté en tant que
morpasien parce que j'ai toujours cru
dans cette intercommunalité et que
c'était le sens de l'histoire parce que
c'est le même bassin de vie avec pour la
plupart des projets structurants les 11
vice-présiden ont été accordés aux élus
de la majorité l'économie et
l'aménagement du territoire restent la
priorité de 50 ans en Yveline la culture
et la santé sont délégué à des
conseillers communautaires les cinq
villes entrantes héritent de poste
important à l'exemple de Joséphine
colmans berger qui obtient la première
vice-présidence alors que plaisir entre
à peine dans 50 ans en Yveline je suis
aussi vice-présidente du département
avec trois délégations
importantes donc je suis pas quelqu'un
qui est là pour couper des rubans je
suis vraiment quelqu'un d'actif et et
j'essaie véritablement de mettre en
place un véritable travail pour
l'intérêt général un conseil
d'agglomération qui ne s'est pas déroulé
sans heure les élus de gauche se sont
estimés exclus de la gouvernance de 50
ans en yeline et ont décidé de ne pas
siéger et de ne pas
voter et l'installation de la nouvelle
agglomération de centtin en yvine s'est
faite sur fond de tension avec
l'opposition la gauche est exclue de
l'exécutive écoutez les explications
ainsi que les réactions des élus par
Wilfried Richy et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud depuis 10h ce samedi 9 janvier
l'opposition ne siège plus dans
l'exécutif de saqutin en Eveline si la
loi le permet la pratique voulait que la
majorité les associé en leur confiant
plusieurs vice-présidences du moins
depuis 2002 dans le passé c'est ce qu'il
y avait il y avait aucun vice-président
de droite aussi hein donc il faut aussi
que on soit raisonnable dans les propos
que l'on peut tenir je maintiens bien
sûr le conseil des maires où les grandes
orientations stratégiques seront données
et en puiss donc je souhaite que toutes
les communes soient associé d'ailleurs
aucune délibération dans l'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin ne pourra être votée en
l'absence d'une commune parmi les 12
communes que compte dorenavant
Saint-Quentin rappelons que H sont
détenus par la droite et alliés je le
disais tout à l'heure en 40 ans de
mandat j'ai jamais vu
organiser un travail comme ça et et et
c'est la seule communauté
d'agglomération où il y a ce principe
moi j'ai téléphoné partout et partout il
y a un partage des responsabilités ce
qui n'empêche pas qu'il y a une majorité
lors de l'installation de la nouvelle
agglomération l'opposition n'a pas
manqué de faire entendre sa colère en
refusant de siéger elle dénonce aussi le
choix de passer à 75 conseillers
communautaires ce qui l'empêcherait
selon elle de se faire entendre lors des
libétion une nouvelle fois puisque je
l'avais déjà fait j'en appelle à la
raison je pense que notre territoire et
surtout les habitants mérite qu'on ait
un travail collectif ce travail
collectif nous sommes disposés à l'avoir
dans une gouvernance partagée avec des
règles c'est maintenant vous savez le
cas dans de l'immense majorité des
intercommunalités aujourd'hui cette
installation fait figure d'anomalie
c'est le fruit de de de ce qui s'est
passé dans les derniers mois en fait la
tension elle est montée ces derni mois
on espère que Michel logier 2è version
sera plus ouvert que Michel logier sur
la fin de la dernière mandature j'espère
en tout cas que les jours qui vont
suivre les semaines et les mois qui vont
suivre ne seront pas dans l'état
d'esprit qui a présidé à la construction
de cette nouvelle agglomération
c'està-dire qu'on revienne un esprit de
travail commun d'élaboration commune du
projet prochaine séance du Conseil
d'agglomération le 30 janvier une séance
pour mettre en place les différentes
commissions et qui devrait également
être agité
enfin nous ferons le point avec wilfri
et Richy ainsu que les élus demain dans
le 78 politique et le ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard casenu a choisi
satori pour présenter ses vœux à à la
gendarmerie nationale le Quartier
Militaire de satori abrite différentes
unités dont le quartier général du gignn
le groupement d'intervention de la
gendarmerie nationale l'occasion de
saluer les différentes unités très
sollicité en 2015 et de passer en revue
les moyens utilisés lors des récents
attentats on estc tout de suite William
l qui était sur place c'est une année
chargée qui s'achève pour les effectifs
de la gendarmerie nationale auquel
Bernard cas-neuve est venu rendre visite
cet après-midi au camp de base de satori
le ministre de l'Intérieur est venu
présenter ses vœux à ses services et en
a profité pour saluer le travail de ses
effectifs sur le terrain en 2015 en
rendant hommage aux représentants des
forces de l'ordre tombé dans l'exercice
de leur fonction le ministre a tenu
également à rappeler la menace
omniprésente terroriste sur le ce
territoire français en annonçant qu'en
2015 il n'y a eu pas moins de 264
interdictions de sortie de territoire et
75 interdictions d'entrée Bernard casenu
a également rappelé qu'il y aura un
nombre de 2137 nouveaux postes créés
dans la gendarmerie nationale et a tenu
à condamner fermement l'agression
antisémite qui a eu lieu ce matin à
Marseille on écoute le ministre de
l'Intérieur je veux avec la plus grande
fermeté condamner cet acte de violence
abjecte
et remercier les policiers de la BAC qui
sont intervenus rapidement pour mettre
hors d'état de nuire l'agresseur je veux
également rappeler que nous sommes dans
un contexte de menace extrêmement élevé
et cet acte témoigne s'il en était
besoin du risque pour certains individus
isolés qui n'étaient pas du tout connus
ni des services de polices ni des
services de
renseignement de passer à l'acte sous
l'influence
de la propagande diffusée notamment sur
les réseaux Internet par daesh et jeudi
dernier c'était à la autour de la
commune de Bois d'Arcy de fêter ses vœux
le maire de la ville Philippe benasaya
du parti les républicains a prononcé un
discours dans lequel il a fait le bilan
de l'année passée création d'un poste de
police développement de la vidéo
protection ou encore lancement de
l'application smartphone de la ville et
de se tourner ainsi vers l'avenir le
maire a souhaité que 2016 soit une année
apaisée et la fin de toute les tyrannies
en
France en plateau ce soir Jacques
fronier directeur d'itinéraire poétique
à Saint-Quentin en Yveline et à la
Mohamed poète et cinéaste syrienne
bonsoir alors vous aurez né ce soir une
soirée donc pour lutter contre
l'obscurantisme au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en yeline à 19h30 suite
aux attentats donc de Charlie Hebdo et
du supermarché hyperccher qui ont eu
lieu donc l'année dernière c'est un
petit peu voilà c'est il y a un
partenair également avec Amnesty
internationale Le Pen Club et la maison
des journalistes alors cette soirée
était initialement prévu le 15 novembre
mais du coup elle a été reportée en
suite aux attentats donc de l'année
dernière ça a une symbolique de le faire
du coup en ce moment la veille enfin oui
c'estd normalement cette cette
manifestation a lieu tous les 15
novembbres depuis 5 ans c'est une
journée c'est la journée internationale
de l'écrivain en prison ce qu'on sait
très peu en France et ça fait 40 ans 30
ans 40 ans que ça existe et nous on
s'est emparé de cette cette thématique
parce que ça correspond complètement à
l'engagement que je je prête et que je
je sais être celui de des poètes à
travers le monde et donc l'annulation de
de la manifestation le 15 novembre et ça
aurait dû être avec la ville de voisin
et je regrette que ce partenariat n'est
pu aller au bout voilà pour fait
d'attentat on a dû arrêter cette
manifestation ne pas la ne pas la
réaliser donc on l'a déplacé et en
cherchant en cherchant une date et un
lieu inévitablement le plus vite
possible Lionel masseta le directeur du
Théâtre de 550 an en nelin me dit écoute
mon théâtre est libre le 11 janvier j'ai
dit oui j'ai dit oui tout de suite mais
honnêtement sans réflexion et c'est
après je me suis dit c'est c'est quand
même incroyable que cette ce ce cet
événement je le je le reporte le 11
janvier c'est-à-dire un an jour pour
jour après les manifestations qui ont
mis dans la rue des millions et des
millions de personnes qui qui qui se
disaient Charlie et quand on entend hier
dire que place de la République il n'y
avait que quelques milliers de personnes
pour les derniers instants de
commémoration des attentats de Charlie
de l'assassinat de la jeune policière et
de l'hypercachère on se dit il y a il y
a quand même un problème donc je dis
c'est bien c'est bien que avec cet
événement on on on on on redonne de la
vigueur à notre petit niveau on est on
est rien là-dedans à notre petit niveau
qu'on redonne une vigueur à cet
engagement que que l'on porte en soi
avec avec force avec énergie avec avec
nos invités dont Allah Qui au mois de
novembre a rencontrer collégiens et
lycéens sur le territoire alors
justement c'est la première fois que
vous participez à cette soirée à la
Mohammad qu'est-ce qui vous a donné
envie de vous investir justement au côté
de Monsieur Fournier
euh c'est la première fois oui et je
remercie beaucoup euh Jacques Fournier
de m'avoir invité
euh moi je trouve qu'on est tous lié
dans ce monde pour
euh par notre acclamation et aspiration
à la liberté à la liberté d'expression à
la c'est-à-dire que je sois syrienne ou
lui français on est on a les même on
porte la même cause humaine et les
preuve ce qui se passe en France en ce
moment là malheureusement ça fait 5 ans
qu'on subit et qu'on souffre de cela en
Syrie et les citoyens syriens pacifique
et ils sont tous les jours euh euh
confrontés à aux menaces terroristes
euh le terrorisme de l'état d'un
régime euh qui qui est vraiment enem
prisonne et essaie de d'étouffer la la
la révolution pacifique qui a démarré
pacifique des Syriens et je faisais
partie moi-même et beaucoup beaucoup de
Syriens ou les les les
extrémistes qui sont rentrés la
Syrie la violence vous savez il il
appelle à la violence donc moi j'ai vu
que c'est c'est c'est la même cause
onemporte les mêmes les mêmes
idé idéaux les mêm idé on mène le même
chemin euh tous les chemins doivent
mener à la liberté d'expression
et là jeen suis vraiment je suis très
touchée d'être
d'être d'être
invité à être à participer à cet
événement alors justement la liberté
d'expression c'est le le thème auquel va
autour duquel va se dérouler la Souret
comment ça va un peu se se passer
justement ver plusieurs interventions il
y a des poètes il y a des musiciens oui
il y aura aura cailleurs d'abord un duo
Iringa qui est un duo de de de
d'artistes de jeunes artistes qui qui
ont écrit une chanson l'an dernier juste
après les attentats et me l'ont proposé
je dis oui venez venez avec la guitare
vous serez accompagné par André
stocketti Le le le flutiste qui qui
accompagnera toute la soirée qui
ponctuera la soirée de de ses flutes et
il y aura deux autres invités Diana
kisimana jeune journaliste burundaz qui
attend de savoir si elle peut avoir son
son droit d'asile et Maxime nbeca qui
depuis euh euh 35 ans vit en France et
et et n de cesse de de de de de
condamner ce qui se passe dans les pays
d'Afrique et principalement au Congo son
propre pays euh et il y aura aussi des
des jeunes du club jeunes théâtre et
poésie de de voisins qui viendront dire
des textes qui sont extraits de
l'exposition que l'on prête tous les ans
au collège et lycées quelques nouvelles
de derrière les barreaux qui qui qui qui
permet aux jeunes de garder de de
prendre le lien de prendre langue et de
prendre lien avec les poètes du monde
puisque c exposition présente des poètes
du monde entier qui à un moment ou un
autre dans leur vie depuis le début du
20e siècle ont connu ou connaissent
encore la persécution savoir que nous on
ne s'arrête pas la parole des poètes
dans cet cet événement là il y aura donc
un journaliste une journaliste Allaha
est aussi cinéa sa parole est
intéressante aussi importante aussi dans
ce domainelà pour moi c'est important de
pouvoir voilà couvrir un petit peu tout
ce chant tout en gardant l'idée de la
langue et cette soirée sera dédiée à
Ashraf Fayyad ce jeune poète palestinien
qui est condamné à mort pour apostasie
en Arabie Saoudite et autour duquel de
nombreux mouvements se mettent en place
avec le Le Pen Club avec la Maison des
écrivains et de la littérature la
Bienale internationale et poètes en
valdeemar le Printemps des Poètes
l'Union des poètes voilà il y a
différents événements qui vont avoir
lieu la prochainement encore en janvier
et on est complètement complètement
investi avec eux pour défendre Ashraf
Fayyad et je sais très bien et à à la me
le dira et on a eu l'occasion de
participer à une soirée ensemble qu'elle
a organisé à l'Institut des des cultures
d'Islam à Paris il y a des des poètes
dans tous les pays et en Syrie qui sont
emprisonnés actuellement et qui sont
torturés qui sont condamnés à mort qui
ne reverront peut-être jamais la lumière
du jour et on on prend parole pour eux
on prend langue pour eux parce que c'est
important il y a des un message
peut-être un un témoignage spécifique
que vous allez apporter ce soir à la
Mohammad du fait aussi de de de votre
activités de cinéaste quelque choseallit
mettre en avant juste je voulais dire
que
ce qui se passe
ailleurs moi je trouve l'humanité c'est
un c'est un c'est une existence
harmonieuse quand on touche à la vie
quelque part qu'elle soit ailleurs pas
chez nous ça veut dire chez nous et et
souffre de ce manque d'une vie humaine
ailleurs
euh ce que je veux dire que ça fait 5
ans qu'on crie en syérie on subit
vraiment une
violence
atroce et pour ça on
peut on peut être très touché par tout
ce qui tout ce qui se passe en France en
ce moment-là parce que on sait qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire cette souffrance c'est
un moyen aussi de mettre en lumière ce
qui se passe en Syrie et qui peut être
parfois oublié oui oui c'est un moyen
d'être
ensemble vraiment d'être ensemble et et
la France c'est un c'est un pays qu'on
aime beaucoup qu'on aimerait bien
ensemble aller vers vers notre but de
stopper cette vague des d'extrémistes
qui envahi le monde et bien ce sera
notre mot de la fin merci beaucoup à
vous deux d'être venu en plateau et nous
avoir parlé de cet événement alors je le
rappelle la soirée dire non à
l'obscurantisme intégrisme au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Eveline ce soir à
partir de 19h30 l'entrée est livre vous
êtes donc les bienvenus et un hommage ce
weekend à Clarissa Jean-Philippe cette
jeune policière municipale tuée le 8
janvier 2015 à Montrouge désormais
médaillé de la Légion d'Honneur elle
aura aussi un squir et une rue à son nom
à carrière sous poissie originaire de la
Martinique elle habitait dans cette
ville des Yvelines depuis 2009 samedi
après-midi les élus de la ville et des
membres de sa famille ont inauguré ce
soir en en son souvenir pardon un report
BOURD cérémonie émouvante ce samedi à
carrière sous poiss un sir a été renommé
au nom de Clarissa Jean Philippe la
policière tué à Montrouge pared
Coulibali élu famille et Riverin sont
venus lui rendre un dernier hommage
c'est très important comme ça on
n'oublie pas
rest dans les mémoires
et de beau discours et c'est vraiment
touchant restera dans notre cœur il y a
un grand vide grand parce c'était une
collègue une amie un grand vide ils
ont fait de belles choses pour Clarissa
elle serait contente elle est contente
je pense l'air de jeu se situe au pied
de l'immeuble où vivait la jeune
policière dans le quartier des bords de
scène un endroit qu'elle appréciait tout
particulièrement la mère de la jeune
fille qui a fait le déplacement de la
Martinique avec son fils se souvient
comme elle habitait là et puis c'est
iici qu'elle faisait son Foutin elle
faisait tout elle venait pour se
ressourcer de la Martinie qu'elle voit
pas encore qu'elle voyait pas ma ma
cousine et moi on on est venu avec elle
nous a emmené partout on a vécu partout
ici là et puis là je vois qu'ils ont
fait ça c'est comme si je revois ma
fille un an après sa disparition
tragique le meurtre de Clarissa dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions relance le
débat sur l'armement des policiers
municipaux une mesure annoncée par
François Hollande quelques jours après
les attentats du 13 novembre aujourd'hui
on a des terroristes qui sont prêts à
tuer tuer de manière gratuite avec des
armes de guerre donc forcément à minima
il faut armer nos policiers il était
temps que le pouvoir politique donne cet
ordre Clarissa Jean Philippe fait partie
des 148 victimes du terrorisme qui ont
trouvé la mort en 2015 sur le sol
français et nous retrouvons comme chaque
lundi Sephora Namani pour la chronique
culturelle bonsoir Sephora alors
aujourd'hui vous allez nous dresser le
portrait de Caroline Vig exactement
alors Caroline Vig j'ai eu la chance de
la rencontrer vendredi dernierve qu'elle
ne monte sur la scène du théâtre espace
Coluche de plaisir très bon spectacle
d'ailleurs qui a fait sal comble 800
places alors Caroline veno a toujours
aimé les spectacles en public parce que
des petites ell se battait lors des
carmèes d'école pour être celle qui
ferait les poésies en public ou les
lectures à l'église mais elle a
découvert le pouvoir de faire rire un
peu plus tard on l'écoute quand j'étais
avocate je suis rentrée dans une troupe
qui s'appelle la revue de luugia qui est
l'Union des Jeunes Avocats et là pendant
ces TR qu années où je fait on écrit des
sketchs sur le milieu du barreau de
Paris et on fait des blagounettes comme
ça et assez sympa et c'est c'est un beau
spectacle qui joue dans les beaux
théâtres comme ça que j'ai fait la
cigare le théatre de la Porte
Saint-Martin et la première fois où un
de mes sketch est passé enfin le premier
la première fois toute première fois la
première vanne qui a fait rire j'avais
envie d'arrêter le sketch et de dire au
gens attendez ça vous a fait rire mais
c'est fou c'est moi qui a inventé la
vanne cétait c'était vraiment magique et
là j'ai ressenti le pouvoir le pouvoir
que ça pouvait faire de faire rire les
autres et je me suis dit ah ouais c'est
génial alors ce n'est pas banal une une
humouriste qui était avant de devenir
mouriste avocate oui exactement elle est
diplômée de parien Panthéon Sorbonne
elle avait une très bonne situation elle
travaillait même dans un gros cabinet
américain et puis en 2005 elle a même
été lauréate de la conférence de stage
du barreau de Paris qui est un concours
d'éloquence et qui lui a permis pendant
un an derrière d'être commise d'office
aux assises de Paris de pouvoir plaider
différentes affaires de braquage de
meurtres ou de viol et puis un jour pour
elle se produit un déclic en fait euh
j'ai perdu mon grand-père et le jour où
il est décédé j'ai réalisé que moi aussi
j'allais mourir ce que j'avais pas du
tout pensé avant et à ce moment-là je me
suis dit est-ce que comme si ça m'arrive
comme mon grand-père d'être sur mon lit
de mort et que je fais le bilan de ma
vie est-ce que j'aurais fait tout ce que
je voulais faire et c'est là où j'ai
réalisé que il fallait absolument que je
fasse ce dont j'avais envie avant qu'il
soit trop tard et c'est là où j'ai
décidé de démissionner et de changer de
vie c'est confusus qui disait un truc
qui marque a marqué ma vie mais j'ai
découvert la phrase après qui dit qu'on
a deux vies et que la deuxième commence
le jour on se rend compte qu'on en a
qu'une et ça c'est l'histoire de ma vie
en fait alors donc dites-moi si j'ai
bien suivi ces foir en 2008 elle se
reconvertit et puis très vite en 2009
elle présente son premier one man show
il était une fée et un an après elle
propose son deuxième standup Caroline
Vigot quitte la robe dans lequel elle
évoque les difficultés d'être une femme
dans les milieux matchistes oui c'est ça
alors elle parle effectivement de la
cause féminine en général mais également
des dysfonctionnements du milieu
judiciaire ceux de la police de Paul
emploi aussi et même de sa mère c'est
très cash on regarde c'est bien le
théâtre alors vous imaginez la première
fois où j'ai revêtu la robe j'étais
j'étais heureuse j'étais fière j'étais
commise
d'office me dire que je suis obligée de
le
faire et que je ne vous coûte rien
voilà pardon c'est mieux qu'une
allez dis-moi mon Cu là est-ce que tu
kiffes je vous rassure quand même
attention quand j'étais avocate j'ai pas
non plus défendu que des débiles ah non
j'ai aussi défendu des innocents j'aime
bien mettre le point là où ça fait mal
et puis dire attendez les gars et on
peut pour montrer les choses qui vous
énervent utiliseer l'humour je trouve
que c'est même d'ailleurs assez assez
efficace notamment par exemple sur des
sujets féminins qui me touchent beaucoup
les femmes enceintes qui sont virées de
leur boulot ou les femmes battues ou de
façon un peu plus intéressante la
recherche de l'orgasme chez les femmes
d'aujourd'hui ce qui n'était pas le cas
de nos grand-mère mon message dans mon
spectacle aujourd'hui c'est sur
l'accomplissement de de ses rêves et
c'est ce que je termine d'illeurs mon
spectacle en disant ça j'ai si vous avez
la possibilité vous avez des rêves
allez-y foncer vivez-les parce que parce
que parce que vous allez réaliser un
jour vous avez qu'une vie alors ça
marche vraiment fort pour elle elle a
été chroniqueuse pour Stéphane Berne
pour Anne Roumanov son spectacle a
rempli soir après soir pendant plus d'un
an la Comédie de Paris et le Palais des
Glaces là elle entame une tournée dans
toute la France plaisir était d'ailleurs
sa première date le 22 et 23 avril
prochain elle sera d'ailleurs à
l'Olympia consécration quand même ultime
pour un artiste elle vient de sortir son
DVD et on pourra en décembre prochain la
retrouver sur grand écran dans un film
qu'elle vient de tourné de Nicolas
Benabou Benamou pardon au côté d'André
dusolier José Garcia et Florence Foresti
m décidément tous les souris merci
Sephora vous disiez que cé un bon
spectacle vous même vous l'avez apprécié
exactement très bon spectacle on a
beaucoup ris vous nous le conseillez oui
vraiment allez-y et bien voilà ce sera
la référence de de la journaliste
culturelle alors attention à ne pas
manquer et dimanche 10 janvier le
magazine carrefour de Saint-Quentin en
ivine accueillé en exclusivité Ann Tod
alors an Tod c'est une jeune écrivaine
phénomène venue de l'ohao an Tod a été
téléchargé plus d'un milliard de fois
sur internet pour sa saga after elle
revenait dédicacer le premier tome de sa
nouvelle saga beforefor sortie jeudi en
France l'électrice était au rendez-vous
par centaine arrivé très tôt le matin la
file d'attente s'é tié sur plus d'une
cinquantaine de mètres de
long c'est mon moment préféré ça me
permet de sentir l'intérêt que les gens
me
portent beaucoup de gens sont venus leur
présence est vraiment incroyable pour
moi j'ai pas les mot c'est mon auteur
préféré je ça c'est tellement
exceptionnel de la rencontrer genre ça
me fait trop plaisir de pour l'avoir en
vrai de pour lui parler lui dire que
c'est c'est livs sont incroyables parce
que franchement c'est c'est trop cool et
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivi tout de
suite vous retrouvez les résultats
sportifs du weekend et un entretien
exclusif avec le basketteur in Montin
Tommy seggor dans le 7 F sport présenté
par Michel elmidoro demain à suivre le 7
F politique également présenté par
Wilfred richin reviendrons sur la
nouvelle agglomération de Saint-Quentin
en ivline quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain pour le journal je vous souhaite
donc une très bonne
[Musique]
soirée